هي معنى الامن الخرطوم يوسف عزت المستشار
السياسي لقوات الدعم السريع نرحب بك استاذ
يوسف لماذا اللجوء الى لغه الحرب
والاقتتال اين هي لغه الحوار استاذ عزت
شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه انا يعني يجب اننا
لما نتكلم او نحلل الهجمه يجب ان ننظر
لاسباب ومسبباتها دائما السريع
واتخذت موقف
للتحول الديمقراطي مساند
لتسليم السلطه بعد قرارات البرهان في
4/7/2022
والدعم السريع التزم بتلك القرارات وقال
انه ثاني لا تراجع عنها لانه التزام امام
الشاب بخروج المؤسسه العسكريه من العمل
السياسي ووقعت قوات الدعم السريع بوقائده
وقع على الاتفاق الاتفاق الايطالي في خمسه
ديسمبر وشاركت في كل الورثه التي عقدت
وشاركت في كل الحوارات
كل
المناشط المصاحبه وكان بيؤكد على موقف
واحد انه لا تراجع عن خيار التحول
الديمقراطي ولا خيار عن ولا تراجع عن
القرار في 4/7
هذا الموقف هو السبب كل الازمه نحن الان
نواجهها لانه كانت هنالك محاولات لاستناء
قائد الدعم السريع من هذه الطريق وهنالك
قوه اخرى لديها مصالح لتعطيل ما تم
الاتفاق عليهم هي انه توقف
الحل السلمي سياسي ايا كان شكله كان
لمصالحها لمصالح وكان للاسف انه البرهان
متعاطف مع هذه
ولديهم التزامات
مع في الاخر في سبيل
حاجه
يجب ان لا نساوي بنجاني والضحيه الدعم
السريع في معسكره في سوبا اصبحت الصباح
وجدت انها محاوطه بقوات
بالقوات وكما اطلاق
ا من الق
وات في حال الدفاع
هذا ما حصل بالضبط يعني يجب ان لا نتحدث
عن حوار بالبندقيه اذا اراد البرهان
الحوار يجب ان لا يكون بالمندوبيه قبل قبل
يوم واحد
فيجب ان يكون بالبندقيه هل الارضيه جاهزه
الان
للتواصل او عقد حوار او دخول وساطه على
الخط يعني
نود ان نفهم منك المشهد في ضوء الدخول الى
ساحه المعركه
[موسيقى]
اسباب الازمه قبل يومين عرضت
بعض قيادات الحياه المسلحه وبعد رموز
المجتمع السوداني
محمد حمدان لانه محمد حمدان لغايه الدعم
السريع متخذ موقف مشان يريد التحول
الديمقراطيل بعد انحياز المستورد حتى الان
وهو يعتذر عن 25 الان في 25 اكتوبر يعتزل
عنه علنا في التوقيع على الاتفاق الايطالي
وقال ذلك كان خط
ا شباب لعوده قوه لديها مصالح ليس لديها
مصالح في التحول الديمقراطي هذا موجود
يمكن الرجوع اليه فاذا الازمه ليست ازمه
شخصيه بين برهان وحميتيه علاقه بالموقف
السياسي لكل منهم هذه هي الازمه التي
نواجهها لك وهذه هي اللغات للحرب
انا اقول لك الان معارك تدور داخل القياده
العامه وفي المحيطه والان هناك قوه مدنيه
مسلحه بدات يتم تسليحه من مخازن الجيش
لتهاجم الدعم السريعي في مقراته كلها الان
هنالك زيف وتزييف للحدائق الجيش مسيطر على
كل مغارات
وهذا كذب كويس الان هنالك كثير من الدعايه
المضاده وهناك هذه الدعايه نعرف من يقف
وراءه والان بعد بعد بعد ان يكون هنالك
تكون هنالك امكانيه
لمواقع الدعم الفريق الناس موجود في كل
الاماكن مسيطره على الاذاعه والتلفزيون
والانزاع بياناته في اذاعه يجب ان يستمع
هذه هي الحقيقه يجب ان لا نغلف الحقيقه
يعني على متى تعول قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان حمادتي قائد هذه القوات على ماذا
يعول في هذه المرحله
يعول على قوته انه قادر يحمي يحمي قادر
يحمي قواته قادر يحمي موقفه لانه لم يفتر
الحرب تمت مهاجمته وتمت مهاجمته في مواقع
اخرى
مسيطر على كل مسلم قوات الدعم السريع
مسيطر على كل الفرد العسكريه في دارفور
مسيطره وبتحفظ في الامن وموجوده هناك
مسيطره في كردفان في موارد كثيره جدا داخل
الخرطوم في في في في اكثر من موقع يعني
الان ينشر انه الجيش
سيطرنا على على معسكر جري فيه 60 دبابه
هذه المعركه التي تدور الان ليس فيها
منتصر نحن لا نتكلم عن انتصار الجيش
لم يو
اجهوا اخواننا هم ابناء الشعب السوداني
لكن
الذي غاده هذه المحرقه
واحنا
لا يعني اجبر على الحرب وتم تمت
واضح من توزيع القناصين في شارع من وضع
الخطط من كيفيه المهاجمه من جره الدعم
السريع الى القاده كل هذه الاشياء عمل
مخطط ويبدو انه خطه من بدري معده يعني خطه
قديمه كويس فالان اللي نحن الان في
المنتصف سيعرف الشعب من المنتصر طيب كل
الخطاب في الاعلام ونحن وانتظرنا وعملنا
سيكذبه الواقع
استاذ عزت تقول بانها بل تؤكد انها ستواصل
هذا القتال حتى تسيطر على كل مواقع
الجيش هل هذا هو الهدف الذي تسعى اليه قوه
الدعم السريع في هذه المرحله
الان كف الاذى قوات الدعم انا كما قلت لك
في البدايه الدعم السريع اجبر على الحرب
وانت الحين تجبر على الحرب
بكل ما تملك وخير الوسيله للد
فاع هي اذا اذا لم البرهان الان الاتحاد
الجيش ووقف وقف العدائيات
سلاح وتوقف ولكن الان الماركه البرهاني
يهاجم يهاجم
يهاجم اشخاص
في الشارع
فهذه حرب هذه حرب
والان انا الان لحظه الحرب شكرا من
الخرطوم يوسف عزه المستشار السياسي لقوات
الدعم السريعه